martin biron christian dufour émilie
nicolas chroniqueuse au devoir que vous
connaissez qu'on verra si vous êtes
d'accord même nicolas beaucoup plus
souvent
bonsoir bonsoir je vous fait rire parce
que je peux pas ne pas vous parler quand
même dû de l'entraîneur chef du canadien
claude julien c'est un poste métier
qu'on au canada au québec qui vit dans
un siège éjectable souvent une passion
pour beaucoup de gens ça tellement bien
débuté cette saison là christian du four
êtes vous avez vous suivi c'est ce que
ces gens de nouvelles quand même que
vous rossa ça car votre attention vous
suivez ça j'avais prévu votre question
heureusement parce que moi je n'y
connais rien mais j'ai demandé à mon
frère et mon frère me dit de vous dire
que les différences entre les arcs et et
la politique peut entre autres des
systèmes de santé c'est que de
l'imputabilité situe livre pas la
marchandise
t out donc c'est ça que je vais vous
dire que la part de mots cela parce que
aujourd'hui qu'aux articles je peux me
sur l'imputabilité qui marque dans le
domaine de la santé dans la prison
comparaît j'ai dû ça avec intérêt
vous nous en avait beaucoup parlé ici là
va aussi martin oui mais moi aussi je
veux faire un parallèle avec la
politique parce qu'on en fait tellement
souvent on utilise les termes de hockey
quand on parle de politique mais six
défaites en huit matches si on avait eu
six mauvaises décisions aux sur huet en
politique ce serait la catastrophe
alors je peux comprendre qu'il y avait
besoin d'un remaniement quand même assez
cocasse que ça tombe le même jour que
celui de françois legault et celui de
françois legault bans deuxième wii et
monsieur legault d'ailleurs qui suit
beaucoup look et qui a commenté
aujourd'hui on dit ah bon mais c'est 10
l'équipe était désorganisée et marc
bergevin a dit claude julié n'arrivait
plus à se faire comprendre
c'est pas qu'ils avaient perdu la
confiance de ses joueurs mais est-ce
comme s'il parlait puis les jeunes
joueurs notamment n'entendait plus
emilie une colonne à verre
aju comment quand vous avez touché ce
matin moi je suis une femme complètement
déconnecté du canadien de montréal
mais ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
j'essaie de faire attention à commenter
des choses donc son amoureux non non non
non moi je suis une fille de québec
j'attends le retour des nordiques
donc je pense que maintenant je sais
s'agit alors un ministre nouveau
ministre responsable de la lutte contre
le racisme nous le recevrons tout à
l'heure benoit charette
je vous fais entendre un extrait
monsieur charest monsieur legault et
réaction de madame anglade et on revient
j'ai l'impression que si j'avais nommé
quelqu'un qui membres des minorités
aurait dû banc c'est bien ils l'ont amis
parce qu est membre d'une minorité
pourtant c'est tous les québécois qui
doivent lutter contre le racisme là on a
eu beaucoup de beaux disques au québec
des beaux débats sémantiques
mais le plus important c'est les
résultats c'est de faire reculer le
racisme au québec par des actions puis
je pense que benoît est la meilleure
personne france
a la base je vous dirais que c'est un
mandat de lutte au racisme donc la
couleur de la peau d'un individu pour
aucune raison ne doit être le critère de
d'exclure cette personne je pense est à
la base même du principe de tout racisme
je suis impliqué dans ces dossiers là
depuis plusieurs années on parlait tout
à l'heure lors d'expériences plus
personnelle à travers ma propre famille
en aucun aucun aucun cas peu importe la
raison à mon sens la couleur de peau ne
doit pas être un argument pour
disqualifier quelques
peu importe la personne qui est choisie
par le gouvernement il faut d'abord
reconnaître le mais les choses se
reconnaître le problème alors on va voir
qualifiant d' énergie ce qui va déployer
à travers un traversier volonté encore
dire ah oui c'est vrai que moi j'ai été
victime
mais finalement c'est pas vraiment d'une
assistance technique alors comment il va
se dépatouiller dans cette danse est
dans ce contexte l âge je ne sais pas
donc madame anglade qui souligne qu il
soit duras et systémique d'une part et
d'autre part est ce qui est ce qu'il y
aura les coudées franches martin france
avec vous j'ai demandé au ministre
lorsque lionel carmant et nadine géraud
aurait pas été mieux placé parce qu'ils
ont été à la tête d'un groupe de travail
sur la question pendant plusieurs
semaines à québec
c'est vrai que c'est surprenant que ce
soit pas un membre du comité il y avait
quand même sept députés membres de ce
comité là et je présume que quand le
premier ministre vous appelle pour vous
offrir de vous occuper d'un dossier vous
dit pas non non non alors je pense que
monsieur legault chercher une mais sur
cherchait un ministre capable de mener
ce dossier là calmement
monsieur legault est pas tellement à
l'aise avec un dossier comme celui du
racisme
il est plus fort en chiffres ça veut pas
dire qu'ils aient pas sincère dans son
geste et qu'il ne veut pas de résultats
mais il voulait quelqu'un d'assez solide
pour être capables de manoeuvrer dans ce
labyrinthe pas facile avec doigté sur
cette question là monsieur charest tu
sais quand même députés d'expérience en
le mans terre d'expérience qui a quand
même connu quelqu'un qui a une
expérience du dossier des communautés
culturelles c'est quelqu'un de très
courtes courtois d'aimables et de calme
et c'est probablement pour cette raison
que monsieur legault l'a choisi
spécifiquement dans ce dossier et
pragmatique qu'on lui dit est très
pragmatique pour ceux qui se posent la
question qui était pas avec nos débuts
de quoi il parle là sa famille c'est que
sa femme est d'origine haïtienne ont eu
à faire l'objet de discrimination pour
un logement il ya plusieurs années intel
izbat ils ont gagné il dit que ses
enfants aussi ont fait l'objet de dresde
acte de racisme etc bref c'est ça
l'expérience familiale je referme la
parenthèse émilie nicolas vous avez
réagi comme en a marre aussi trouvé ça
intéressant juste en fait le clip de
monsieur beaucoup que vous venez passer
sur le fait que bon la couleur de peau
des terrasses et beaucoup ce message qui
est et qui était martelé un petit mois
l'exemple qui m'est tout de suite venue
en tête c'est celui de secrétaire à la
condition féminine nous fédéral le
ministère le ministère qui évoque change
de nom à chaque année depuis la donc
mais sur à chaque année c'est ainsi un
mini station pas ce qui est donné à une
femme mais c'est aussi un poste si on
verrait si jamais avant un homme qui
était donné on verrait pas cet homme le
dire ben moi j'ai une mère jeune femme
moi j'ai des enfants j'ai une fille
donc c'est pour ça que je suis sensible
et raconte son fils c'est pas
nécessairement une critique du taux du
ministre d'ailleurs dans son ensemble
dans son discours officiel d'ouverture
c'est pas lui qui a mené ce sont les
journalistes qui l'ont amenée sur cette
question sur ce que sont leurs a amené
sa famille comme une pièce mans comme
une table avec de compétences ou
sensibilité mais c'est mais c'est
intéressant on ferait jamais ça en fait
sur le dossier des femmes mais sur son
dossier leur ont fait
et puis moi c'est ce double et en ce
temps là on fait qui me fait poser des
questions sur ce cru en fait non ce
qu'on fait sur la rencontre ait jamais
sur notre faim et christian ben je pense
que aux états unis ou au canada anglais
se serait inimaginable qu'on n'aime pas
une personne de couleur pour ce genre de
post l'a donc la différence identitaire
québécoise est très marquée je pense que
monsieur legault le dis très clairement
le ministre le dit aussi
c'est la compétence qui doit primer donc
c'est la question qu'on doit se poser
est quel point est il compétent pour
faire le travail
sa nomination a été fossilisé assimile
accueilli tu comptes faire y compris de
son père regroupement de noir québécois
c'est quelqu'un que la réputation en
fait de livrer la marchandise d'être
assez efficace et pas de très bons dans
la communication
je trouve le fait que ça lui a été
reproché le fait que sa conjointe
christiane surtout qu'ils aient des
enfants métis qui ont fait l'objet de
discriminations qui a porté une plainte
devant la commission des droits de la
personne que jugé en sa faveur qui
rappelons que la personne discriminait
ce n'est même pas un blanc je trouve ça
montre qu'une sensibilité filantes pour
le dossier et je trouve que l'analogie
avec les femmes dont parle madame
nicolas moi je trouve qu'un gros
sophisme se passer la différence entre
les hommes et les femmes la vie
scientifique elle est réelle et des
fondamentale la différence entre les
races à la fois scientifique
vous avez dit pas c'est quelque chose de
culturel l'europe aux logiques de
l'existant on constate un changement de
vision québécoise on va voir parce qu'à
montréal madame planté elle adhère
totalement à la vision du
multiculturalisme crise économique
quelqu'un en fait dans cet esprit le
très controversé donc moi on jugera aux
résultats jeudi à quel point la
commissaire oré systémique à montréal va
livrer les marchandises par rapport à
monsieur charest just the way we may
line carey est ce que une fois vous avez
dit ça que l'unc le parallèle on ne peut
pas imaginer un homme responsable du
ministère sur la condition féminine
une fois que j'avais 10 ans est-ce que
vous pensez que ça peut qu il peut par
ses qualités par ailleurs faire avancer
les dossiers de façon concrète au québec
même si ses qualités que vous regardez
mais c'est aussi le contexte c'est à
dire que si c'est pas lui que par
exemple au début au débat pas
régulièrement 2 0 c2c deux personnes en
fait puis dans un dans un monde où le
caucus dacca qui est pas très
diversifiées ce que ça veut dire c'est
que on force son fort serait finalement
ces deux personnes là à prendre ce
dossier là alors que ayant fait d'autres
intérêts
c'était pas ça lance en politique donc
tant sous entend que finalement une sous
représentation de la diversité à
l'assemblée nationale
ça fait que soi lire quelques rares élus
qui sont à suivent et sont forcés à
prendre ce dossier là brandon ces
dossiers des roses en maîtres la
majorité c'est ce problème sont
intéressants ouais non mais c'est fort
intéressant parce qu'effectivement
monsieur legault a plaidé ce qui te rend
bien si j'avais donné sa nadine jérôme a
réduit mais ça y est vous la cantonner
dans ces sujets là alors je veux qu'elle
fasse autre chose vous dit
émilie nicolas si on avait beaucoup plus
des représentants des minorités à
l'assemblée nationale est partout cette
histoire on se poserait pas comme ça
exactement donc là on est dans un piège
finalement où on essaie de choisir un
petit mais messi s'il n'y avait pas ce
déficit de représentation conclusion
christian là dessus mais moi je serais
content qu au québec trop tôt fait ces
nominations là on n'adhère pas une
vision d'une société racialisées je
trouve que la principale critique à
l'égard de monsieur la principale
réserve à l'égard de monsieur charette
qui est aussi ministre de
l'environnement dans compte fait qu'est
la lutte contre le racisme c'est un
dossier important délicat est-ce qui va
avoir le temps l'énergie pourrait
consacrer suffisamment de l'énergie jeu
thomas seydoux c'est le moi c'est ça qui
m'a touché parce qu' il n'y ait pas
juste responsable de cela mais je m'en
allais lamartine c'est l'environnement
l'appui pour la cac qui ont dû pas les
bouchées doubles là dessus ce n'est pas
leur sport favori au tout début
est-ce que c'est pas envoyer un drôle de
message quand même puis lui demander
beaucoup à monsieur charest est à cet
égard je vous dirais que c'est peut-être
pour cette raison que son accueil mitigé
c'est à dire que les tenants du de
l'environnement s'inquiètent à savoir
est ce que monsieur charest tu vas avoir
encore le temps de s'occuper de notre
dossier et on l'a vu en éducation
monsieur robert j'avais beaucoup de
difficulté à s'occuper de l'enseignement
supérieur il y en a qui disaient ils
s'en occupent le vendredi après midi
alors est ce que et c'est sûr qu'il va y
avoir il va devoir mettre des priorités
est placé
ces dossiers mais c'est certain que
monsieur charest tout fait pour chasser
sur le dossier de l'environnement parce
que c'est un dossier qui est cher à
beaucoup d'élus ici je dirais que
monsieur legault a compris que il
pourrait pas gagner ces élections sans
avoir quelque chose à dire sur le front
environnement tour de table sur lucie
lecours qui devient ministre délégué à
l'économie on va l'entendre le premier
ministre on revient
l'économie québécoise c'est beaucoup le
tissu serré des pme je vais mettre comme
je disais tout à l'heure tous mes
efforts à aider ces entrepreneurs
entrepreneurs à grandir à se moderniser
à s'équiper à exporter lorsque ce sera
possible
et pierre fils kevin et marie-ève proulx
avait besoin de renfort je pense que mon
ambition d' éliminer l'écart de richesse
du québec avec le reste du canada les
etats-unis ça va prendre des mandats
l'uci va s'occuper des pme mais ils
seront pas trop de trois ministres pour
répondre à mes ambitions de créations
d'emplois au québec
bon martin s'intéresse à elle n'est pas
très connue
voici que les codes et les l'équipe
économique
on vient renforcer l'équipe il ya
beaucoup de choses à dire pas tellement
je voudrais sur lui si le cours qu'on ne
connaît pas beaucoup mais sur le dossier
de l'économie
c'est sûr qu'on s'en va vers la relance
économique et que monsieur legault vu du
résultat j'ai déjà dire cette émission
que pierre fétigué bones est elle
vraiment un véritable numéro deux de ce
gouvernement et ce que pierre fait ce
bébé ne veut généralement il l'obtient
monsieur fatigue est bonne ce per
commissaire à l'éthique mais ce souhait
bas ça c'est une autre histoire mais
mais il a des gros dossiers économiques
à livrer et il ya beaucoup de petits
dossiers qui tourne autour ça ne les pme
le développement régional
alors marié coup n'est pas une ministre
qui performent bien
au sein de ce cabinet là alors monsieur
legault a décidé d'ajouter madame le
cours qui est une femme de plus il était
également critiqué pour sur le fait
qu'il avait
dégommer deux femmes de son cabinet
alors j'en fais mon coeur une ça donne
de l'espoir au caucus mais aussi ça
permet à pierre fitzgibbon d'avoir les
coudées un peu plus franches le pour
aller chercher des gros deals
l'expression christian monsieur legault
en fait ça a toujours été ça on t'aime
de départ en fait le rattrapage
économique du québec par rapport à son
environnement
puis depuis deux ans en fait il toujours
dépassée par d'autres dossiers d'une
prochaine le sur la laïcité juli blocage
autochtones qui ont oublié millions
était très important est évidemment la
pandémie la pandémie le racisme peut
être la langue française donc il renfile
encore pour essayer en fait de nous
communiquer le message pour on sent la
prochaine campagne électorale qui va
commencer parce que sinon secret de
polichinelle que c'est là dessus qu'il
veut débattre de ce devant les québécois
je pense pas qu'ils veulent juste parler
de la pandémie en vous et moi donc il ya
c'est encore d'honorer intéressé à 100
mais mon dieu que des distractions
oui émilie nicolas c'est les deux
dossiers tant fédéral que professeur
convoi qui touche le plus les gens le
premier c'est la candélie le deuxième
c'est la relance économique la pandémie
la gestion des pandémies et françois
lebon c'est un peu compliqué ça dépend
désormais par le secteur puis les
opinions sont un peu partagé là dessus
même si avec la p2 de la position
sachant sa réponse en main n'est pas
direct sur sa popularité au nouveau dans
la violence économique d'accord avec les
autres panélistes que c'est plus dans sa
zone de confort vous c'est quelque chose
dont il aime parler maintenant ça va
être vraiment de voir le le plan
conquêtes je pense que tout peu importe
où les gens font campagne en 2021 dans
le monde
s'il ya des campagnes à venir le thème
de l'économie va être très fort on sort
d'une crise économique puis au delà de
la question de qui et en rattrapage par
rapport à qui d'autre dans le monde je
pense qu'on est juste un rattrapage par
rapport à l'an passé il ya deux ans j'ai
vraiment des reculs importants qui ont
été faits des pertes d'emplois qui ont
été faites aussi donc c'est c'est l'idée
c'est d'avoir un discours aussi qui va
être proche des gens proches des
réalités d'aider des personnes qui en ce
moment et on voyait juste encore la
semaine passée le les files devant les
livres et prier les gens les gens les
gens de la misère transformant québec
jeudi
franchement comme ça donc ce dossier là
ça prend des ministres qui vont avoir
beaucoup d'empathie mactac
puis qui vont sonner proche des réalités
économiques des gens qui ont vraiment
souffert de cette très bien petit
dernier sujet avant de se quitter
vidéo des reines o'toole on va écouter
pas toutes les vidéos s'il vous plaît
juste quelques secondes où il montrait
le nouveau bureau de monsieur trudeau
s'il était battu
on écoute
[Musique]
c'est un vidéo de juin dernier ont ils
dit voici son prochain bureau puis il
montre une toilette
je vous pose la question très
franchement est ce une autre gaffe même
site en juin dernier une autre gaffe
martin c'est pas sa meilleure
on peut le dire quand même si warren
buffett qui disent ça prend vingt ans
pour faire sa réputation pour cinq
minutes pour la perdre
je dirais quand même que ce phénomène
présentement qui est limité aux médias
sociaux il ça fait pas beaucoup de ne
savait pas tâche d'huile j'irai au
québec mais c'est ça peut coûter cher ce
genre de blague là il y avait vraiment
la s'amuser wilson blame sans attaquer
mais est-ce que ça aide a aussi élevé le
débat christian la confusion c'est que
ça ne grandit pas pour quelqu'un qui
veut être premier ministre
ce qu'elle veut c'est un peu jeune je le
dis on a la mémoire courte
jusqu'à quel point ce avoir laissé des
traces permanente je suppose ou non et
emilie mais je sers en fait c'est la
deuxième fois que des vidéos comme ça de
rêver notre circuit
les deux fois sur le même dossier celui
là c'était parce que le bloc l'ange rien
changé dénonce maintenant une beyrouth
buy in qui trouvent que temps n'efface
mans de l'histoire de monsieur langevin
qui en fait un jouet dans la création
des peuples autochtones ses seuls
contacts se déroula y en a un autre qui
est sorti à l'automne dernier parce
qu'ils défendent est le fondateur de
l'unité personne qui est aussi qui est
un collègue flamand de l'enjeu est donc
si on dirait que c'est ce dossier leur
qui équipent en sorte qu'ils aiment
aussi autour des liens émotifs pire un
ton qui est vraiment en fait reprocher
on va dire on est sincèrement donc à
voir si ça aura des conséquences non
merci à vous trois puis je vous parle
plus de la caisse et premier merci
beaucoup
la proche pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici r d
oh